and Kevin you you bought your kids back
to Philadelphia
yes but not for like ebonheart day you
brought them back to where you're from
yes then why did you bring them back
well you know I'm parenting is something
I take pride in you know I want to make
sure that my kids understand the value
of hard working and what the meaning
behind it should be so you know I don't
want you thinking that what we have in
our lifestyle is how it's supposed to be
because it's not yeah there's a reality
behind it so I'm gonna take you to where
dad is from so we take a trip you know
we take a real trip to Philadelphia and
you know we land and I sent me show you
where I grew up so you can understand in
your
listen every lesson has a moment of
disbelief just follow me for a second
didn't start till we got off the plane
and start driving through the
neighborhood where else then that's what
it is where are you from we pull up to
my place
and should I give this long speech it's
like a moment like it's like 7:00 a.m. I
got there with nobody would be there and
I'm like look I didn't have okay look
this is this is all week this is the
grass cities no think that's all the
grass we had but here I walked two and a
half miles to get from here to where I
had to go to meet my mom this was not a
situations you were comfortable in like
it done and my kids like
[Applause]
this place is a piece of [ __ ] it's gotta
work for let's go upstairs I literally
had to stop the lesson go back home I'm
just gonna show you books from now on
[Applause]
[Music]
you